Connie's house wasn't the only thing
that got demolished in the Young Sheldon
finale — our hearts did, too. And one
scene in particular had fans sobbing.
Longtime fans of the "Big Bang Theory" spin-off
"Young Sheldon" know all too well that the show
has no trouble reining in the comedy in exchange
for heartfelt and dramatic moments. However,
even they weren't prepared for what the
Season 6 finale, "A Tornado, a 10-Hour Flight,
and a Darn Fine Ring," brought them.
When a tornado touches down in Texas,
the shock of the disaster prompts the
scattered members of the Cooper clan to
reconsider their interpersonal
relationships and situations.
There are plenty of emotional moments
from the episode to go around,
but viewers were especially struck by the
scene where Cooper family patriarch George
Sr. and Missy reconcile over their recently
frayed relationship while stuck on the side
of the road. Missy, who has been dealing
with quite a bit of teenage angst lately,
owns up to her recent actions, while
George does his best to comfort her.
After the episode aired on May 18, 2023, many
fans online were vocal regarding how this scene,
as well as the rest of the episode,
made them feel. As one Redditor wrote:
"I started crying when George and Missy were
hugging each other on the side of the road."
As it turns out, they were far from
the only person who shed some tears.
Several "Young Sheldon" fans noted that
they were surprised by how much they reacted
emotionally to George and Missy's bonding
scenes and the Season 6 finale in general.
"I don't think I've ever cried at a show like
I did with this one. Missy and George bonding
moment was killer and then following it
up with Connie's house being destroyed."
Even fans who weren't as hot on the
overall episode and its plotlines
found the moment quite compelling. One user noted:
"I really didn't like the use of a tornado to
resolve everyone's feelings after a fight for a
second time, but they did it just as well as the
first time. I cried at the end at Connie's house
and George's ability to step in and protect
himself and Missy. Incredibly endearing."
"I'm sorry. I'm sorry for everything."
Particular praise was heaped upon
Raegan Revord's performance as Missy,
as fans found her to be the
standout character of the episode.
Even while fans on Reddit discussed how much they
loved George Sr. and Missy's emotional moment,
several other parts of the episode came
up in conversation. The destruction of
Meemaw's house and the overall chemistry of the
"Young Sheldon" cast members were discussed,
as were the unexpected actions of the
often shady and condescending Pastor
Jeff Difford. Instead of ratting her out,
he keeps his lips sealed about the gambling
room Meemaw runs within her laundromat
— largely because of the fate of her
home and the traumatic experience they
just endured in the form of the tornado.
One Reddit user described Jeff's uncharacteristic
decision as one of the highlights of the Season 6
finale, while another fan feels this
was a rare example of Jeff choosing
his humanity over his faith. Still, one
person isn't exactly overjoyed by Jeff
choosing to look out for Meemaw, calling
him out for his inconsistency, writing:
"Why can't he forgive the "sin" of
Georgie getting Mandy pregnant out
of wedlock when this guys first wife
hated him so much and then left him."
All in all, the closer of "Young Sheldon"
Season 6, "A Tornado, a 10-Hour Flight,
and a Darn Fine Ring," doesn't seem to
have left fans of the show disappointed.